[Musique]
à tous de la serre à tous de leicester
débarquement la crs numéro 4 étaient
présentes le 4 décembre place des
invalides face aux étudiants un an plus
tard dans son cantonnement de
lagny-sur-marne la même compagnie en
plein entraînement
d'accord ça commençait un peu à donner
un peu de partout à des fois on a peu on
a un peu peur c'est comme tout le monde
on peut penser quelque chose et pensez
quoi
et puis si on est des pros tellement de
penser surtout d'ouvrir c'est ça le
problème
très efficace c'est un produit qui n'est
pas toxique lorsqu'il est utilisé en
plein air mais vous l'avez vu par vous
même tout à l'heure et qui interdit une
réaction trop vive de la part de ceux
qui le subissent
la règle pour le lancement des chronos
c'est quoi exactement c'est sûr on du
commandant l'unité monsieur nous
envoyons l'aigreur grenade uniquement
sur ans du commandant de vittek qui juge
la situation donne des arbres hauts
gradés responsable des ffg les fusils
lance grenades qui sont ici une batterie
composée de 4 mg et c'est sûr en dehors
de ce commandant que nous envoyons des
types de grenades approprié n'est ce pas
soit par roulement ou alors soit entier
regroupée qui attend plus le tir tendu
est strictement interdite c'est
strictement interdit et ça et nous
obéissons à des règles qui sont strictes
dans ce domaine il y a un an pourtant
parmi d'autres blessés très graves
un étudiant père un oeil arraché par une
grenade lancée à tirs tendus
il n'y a pas que les crs qui ont des
effets g il ya les crs y est les mobiles
et les gars de la pp il ya d'autres
fonctions des faits j'ai alors en france
qui est noir c'est un crs non non non
faut savoir faire la différence entre
eux acer est un mobile agenda mobile
disons un gars qui travaille la pp ce
sont des choses différentes sont des
gars différent des les sections
différentes donc ce qu'il ya c'est que
chaque fois qu'on voit quelqu'un a bien
en noir casqués ont dit que ça crs non
c'est faux
et ça c'est énervant c'est assez
énervant parce que on ramasse tout on
ramasse tous les bavures
voyez rassembler durant des heures l'an
dernier c'est l'attend face à une petite
poignée de casseurs dans les actes
peuvent donner une image impopulaire des
manifestations au plus haut niveau les
ordres thaler à venir participer aux
manifestations l'an dernier oui qu'est
ce que vous pensez lorsqu'on vous fait
attendre trois heures dans un coeur
avant d'avoir une consigne aux heures
n'en a qu'un c'est le plus important
c'est trois heures devant les
manifestants à se prendre des 10 objets
sur la figure sans rien faire vous
pensez quoi ce moment-là penser que les
ordres ont un peu tardé l'an dernier
le 5 décembre les voltigeurs sont lâchés
dans le quartier latin
quelques instants plus tard malik
oussékine succombe beaucoup les
conditions où ils étaient ces garçons là
moi je serais resté chez moi si j'avais
été malade commune était comme il était
lui je pense qu'il aurait pu rester il
n'aurait pu 500 par les malins semble
prendre deux parties mais avec ce qu'il
avait je pense qu'il aurait pu rester
chez lui ce jour-là une heure éviter
parce qu'il avait déjà été pour une fois
je prends ce matin et tout ce que je
peux vous répondre
entre deux entraînements la compagnie se
détend pensante à son départ prochain
pour la nouvelle calédonie moyenne d'âge
de la crs numéro 4 30 ans
dans la cour les toutes dernières
recrues en plein entraînement
vous êtes chef d appeler crs nous mêmes
absolument
absolument on serre est juste que vous
vous avez fait le mois de décembre
dernier n'ont pas non j'étais en stage
vous êtes appelés oui du contingent 86
87 8 et vous demander à être cher s wifi
en train de préparer le concours
gardiens de la paix puis après je sais
adressée dans les six races et pourquoi
c'est une vocation
on voit ce que ça me plaît comme on
vient de faire rien de faire un mois
puis j'ai eu que ça me plaisait ça me
ferait mieux d'en adopter dans les
autres corps de police
j'attends toujours
vous légalement être crs crs je ne sais
pas mais rentrer dans la police
certainement qu'est ce que vous faisiez
l'an dernier étudiant il vous étiez vous
allez manifester
manifester oui et non comme tout le
monde ça veut dire quoi les invalides
aux yéti ou pas non j'étais pas et les
autres manifs
j'ai fait une ministre un an signe chez
moi c'est marrant ça y est après les
manifs étudiantes de l'an dernier vous
voulez devenir crs vous pouvez nous
expliquer je n'ai pas cherché ces restes
chez tu fais mon service dans la police
avant de rentrer dans le camp de la
police
il m'avait l'air très attentif à ce que
j'avais pourquoi forfait lorsque c'est
mon rôle
est ce qu'à votre avis sont très
attentifs à la tension vous leur portez
là j'ose l'espérer
vous étiez étudiant l'an dernier oui
j'étais étudiant il avait fait les
manifestations non delitoon
volontairement oui et pourquoi est ce
que ça ne m'intéressait pas on sait qu'à
n'était pas juste ben non j'ai rien à
dire là-dessus c'est personnel est ce
que votre vie un lien entre le fait est
qu'aujourd'hui vous soyez service
national police et peut-être crs demain
et le fait que vous n'ayez pas fait les
manifestations il ya un an
mais disons oui j'avais l'intention de
rentrer dans la police puis du fait pour
ça que je n'ai pas fait des manifs là
j'étais pas du côté des étudiants de
quel côté vous étiez du côté de la
police fasse plus tôt ce concept ses
personnages mutants rien dire fin de la
journée retour en famille papa crs maman
au foyer et les enfants qui rentrent du
collège ou du lycée des gosses et
anonymes ont fait son métier
ils sont contre les siècles six postes
bien écoutez monsieur moi j'estime qu'un
fonctionnaire de crs n'a pas besoin se
poser ce type de questions agissent en
unités constituées dans un cadre légal
ma foi lorsque l'ordre de charger
données vous savez comment ça se fait
vous avez vu comment ça se passe au
cours de la journée vous avez vu comment
ça se passait eh bien lorsque l'ordre de
charger de néma fois nous agissons dans
un cadre légal nous n'avons pas à tenir
compte des personnes que nous avons en
face de l'ovalie quand sortent haut
quand il ya eu l'histoire du moteur qui
avait frappé des jeunes
[Musique]
alors tout le monde disait orwell bon
enfin 10 et du gros mots fallait dire 18
plein de trucs comme ça ils croient que
c'est tjrs alors que du pain du crs et
tu leur dis toi que c'était pas laisser
la grèce ce qui est prédit crs ton père
est lourd et port au nom il entend
attaquer quelqu'un chez vous en a parlé
qu'est ce qui se disait baj telle greffe
d'abord répondre à une journée quand tu
as eu la mort de malik et ils ont
organisé ça puisque tout le monde avait
ce jour-là le droit de faire un jour à
lundi et donc on arrêtait condamne
journée de travail et les professeurs
ont été d'accord alors
ce ça fait comme une manifestation par
rapport à la mort quoi pour prouver que
ce n'était pas une journée pour
présenter sa mort à lui est ce que ça
vous satisfait quand même ce que disent
vos enfants sur malik oussékine c'est à
dire votre fille elle a fait grève
elle a dit ce n'était pas normal ma
fille n'a pas fait graves ma fille n'a
pas fait grève alalalala subi ma foi la
grève de ses professeurs
elle a subi la grêle de ses professeurs
alors que les profs qui vous agréent
noms des élèves on à la fin c'était une
journée organisée déjà bien à l'avance
par des étudiants et on a participé mon
opinion ça nous donnait toujours une
journée ça me semble normal ce moment
non mais enfin c'est une réaction c'est
une réaction de deux jeunes ma foi et
qui est louable
à mon avis qui est louable et la maman
fait ce qu'elle en pense je trouve que
c'est bien une raison
leur idée tout ça qu'est ce que tu dis
futur serra junior
[Musique]